parler sérieusement ça ne va pas être
compliqué tu es une méchante sorcière
mais si c'est très compliqué c'est très
compliqué de tuer une méchante sorcière
et vous avez pensé à cette pauvre jeune
fille je pense qu'elle vous aiment
vraiment elle finira par oublier comme
toutes les autres
c'est une belle sorcière plein de beaux
sorcier viendront frapper à sa porte
or chacun de vos mensonges et un pas de
plus vers le donjon de la cité des mots
notre dis pas que ce sont des mensonges
titouan plutôt que ce sont les pavés de
la route qui mène à la grandeur à caen
mais je sais on va faire d'une tour vous
vous excuserez d'avoir menti en
prétendant être le magicien et de vous
être moqué de cette ligne vous devrez
prendre affectés pour être crédible il
faudra essayer de pleurer vous savez
pleurer sinon j'ai plus rien l'oignon
nous ne ferons pas demi-tour
nous trouverons la méchante sorcière
nous livrerons sa baguette magique je
recevrai une montagne de pièces d'or et
toi tu recevras une montagne de bananes
voilà les bananes non je vois parce que
je suis un singe jeunes forcément les
bananes n'est ce pas encore ainsi vieux
stéréotypes tu n'aimes pas les bananes
si j'adore les bananes forcément je suis
un singe mais ce que je déteste c'est
votre façon de dire